hey welcome everybody good morning
thanks all of you for making it here
i'm daniel buckling i'm the lead product
manager for google plus and i want to
start off our session today just by
acknowledging and thanking those of you
in the room who already use google plus
in your organization's today
show of hands who already uses that's
great to see awesome thank you guys um
you've all shown us through your
experience the power of Google Plus to
transform company culture to unlock
innovation and to foster communications
across organizational boundaries you've
all also provided us with valuable
feedback on things we can do to make
Google Plus work even better for your
organization's thank you we appreciate
you and everything you do and we're
looking forward to continuing to work
with you today we'll talk about how
we're taking your feedback and building
the next generation of Google Plus for
the enterprise we'll spend the next hour
together focused on three things first
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
ways that companies are using Google
Plus today to transform their company
cultures then for the first time ever
I'm truly excited to be able to tell you
about the 2017 roadmap for Google Plus
what we've got planned and the features
that we're going to be launching
specifically targeted at enterprises and
then finally we'll close our session
with a panel discussion in QA where a
few of our customers have kindly agreed
to come and talk about their experiences
using Google Plus in their companies
over the last few months I've had the
privilege of having a number of
discussions with businesses about what's
keeping them up at night and across
industries between departments and
across geographies there's one concern
that comes up time and time again how
can I make sure that my company is
delivering innovation that we stay ahead
of the curve that we're getting the most
out of our employees
in short how can I drive innovation at
Google we've seen that innovation
happens when you bring people together
that when you break down boundaries and
barriers and make it easy for people to
share ideas exciting things happen on
the Google+ team our aim is to help you
drive innovation by connecting your
company connecting your people their
ideas their interests their insights
this means making it easy for people to
connect in different locations to share
best practices for leadership to be able
to take the company's pulse and to keep
people in the loop and for everyone at
every level of your organization to stay
connected and to feel like they're truly
part of a team with companies more and
more dealing with teams spread out
across the world employees who spend
most of their time in the field large
workforces where it's not always easy to
know what's going on or who the experts
are this can really be a challenge we
believe the Google Plus is uniquely
positioned to help and we hear this
repeated by those of you who have
already adopted Google Plus in your
organization's so we hear things like
this we would never have achieved this
level of communication and collaboration
without Google Plus Google Plus breaks
down the invisible walls between
disparate departments and creates new
connections Google+ connects us like
never before now we can share expertise
build relationships this little gets us
going this is what brings us in to work
every morning it gets us excited and
there are three main ways that we
believe Google+ can help connect your
company and drive innovation encouraging
knowledge sharing engaging employees and
facilitating
your communication first and foremost
our job is to facilitate knowledge
sharing we do this with tools that allow
teams to better communicate internally
and smarts that automatically uncover
untapped knowledge from across your
organization this is knowledge sharing
that breaks down organizational silos
and connects across geographies second
you know the more engaged employees
produce better work output you tell us
this all the time and Google Plus
provides a really easy and scalable
channel for employee engagement across
your organization letting everybody get
involved finally we hear loud and clear
the importance of secure communication
within and between teams this is of
course a theme that you'll be hearing
throughout the week this week with
robust sharing controls and dedicated
spaces for private discussions Google+
provides a reliable secure and scalable
channel for your organization to
communicate with these three pillars in
mind I'm going to touch briefly on some
of the most widely used features of
Google+ in the enterprise and talk a
little bit about how companies are using
those features today I'll start off with
what's one of the most widely used tools
in Google+ and something that's really
near and dear to my heart which is
community communities and Google+ allow
groups of employees to come together in
a dedicated place to talk about
something specific so those of you who
are using Google+ already probably
already know this right company
communities can be locked down to just
your company they can be locked down to
just specific teams or groups of people
and made private so that you can have
really secure confidential conversations
in them we've had lots of inspiring
stories that come in about companies
using communities to transform the way
their team and their companies work
from collaborating on a team through
allowing employees to organize social
groups to sharing customer stories one
of the most interesting customer
examples that I've heard about
communities comes from a global bank and
this bank was really struggling with how
do we find out about maintenance issues
at our ATM how do we make sure that
we're deploying people to go fix them
and the thing that they latched on to as
a potential solution for this with you
know we've actually got a whole ton of
branch employees who were already
distributed all across the globe what if
we could leverage those employees so
what they did was they employed they
enrolled all of their branch employees
into a large community so 30,000
employees in a community and all of them
were then transformed into essentially
ATM mystery shoppers they were able to
take pictures and make posts and file
complaints when they notice issues in
the field that then allowed maintenance
personnel to go out and address those
issues problem-solve
of course we also rely on communities at
Google as well and so teams will often
have communities for their own internal
discussion talk about hey what features
should be we be developing what are you
hearing from customers how are we
addressing this particular concern
really get discussion going on specific
teams then there's folks to serve Google
broadly right the Google
Travel teams a team that helps Googlers
who are traveling around the globe to
visit other offices or customers they've
got a community where anyone any Googler
can ask a question hey you know what do
I do about customs or does anybody know
how to get a visa to this place I've got
a surprise trip coming up then other
Googlers are able to answer their
questions really quickly lots were much
more scalable solutions to serving their
needs and one thing close to my heart
product managers also have a community
where we're able to share tips and
tricks and how to do our job better
right like what's something that works
for you I'm having this issue how would
you guys approach it
really easily communicate even though
product managers tend to be distributed
you know one in one team one and another
team and so it can potentially be very
difficult to share knowledge and best
practices across that kind of a
distributed group so that's communities
another tool we offer to facilitate
knowledge sharing is what's called
collections those of you who have used
Google Plus in the past couple years
probably notice the addition of this
collections our individual stream so as
particular employee can create a
collection about a specific topic
sort of like micro blogs and they allow
folks to focus their message on a
specific topic so for example one
customer executive uses a collection to
share things that he's hearing about
industry trends and get them out to the
whole company in a lightweight way that
doesn't require him to email everybody
but in a way that facilitates sharing at
Google we've got a developer advocate
who started a collection called h g RW
how Google really works
how do people really work well he finds
posts that other people are making
here's how we do this and in this part
of Google here's you know here's how we
develop products over here Horace hello
developing these concerned and really by
sharing this into a single collection
he's brought together a whole bunch of
knowledge from across Google about what
makes our culture unique M at a higher
level when you look at all of this and
bring it all together Google Plus
provides a window for executives to
understand employee sentiment so one of
the things that can be hard when you're
you know in headquarters to figure out
what you know what's really going on
with my employees how are they really
feeling so for example you could monitor
employee chatter and communities figure
out what are their real concerns
essentially highlight specific needs for
improvement in your
Asian leaders can take advantage of
features like polls to test ideas you
know we're thinking about marketing this
new product we've got a few names what
do you guys think about this and and to
get a sense of employees reactions to
suggestions for example there was an
airline who was finding it really pretty
difficult to connect with their
employees who were you know on flight
crews are out in the field and
operations folks are on the go all
across the globe really difficult to
talk to all of them at once and so they
set up global and regional communities
where the CEO when other leaders were
able to post messages so they were able
to get to everybody all across the globe
and interact with their employees on the
go if they had the mobile apps right and
then the corporate communications team
is able to see things that people shared
into that community and gauge their
response it kind of keeps their finger
on the pulse of what's happening in
their organization
finally the home stream and
notifications ensure that employees
don't miss out on important messages
regardless of where in the company they
are so these sections as you know if you
already use Google+ include updates from
things that they're already following as
well as smart suggestions for things
across the company that they should be
aware of but aren't necessarily
following yet for example many
executives that Google post publicly
restricted to google.com of course and
when they want to communicate with their
teams and this gives them a channel to
communicate on a range of subjects so
they wouldn't necessarily want to send a
full heavyweight email on the ability
for these posts to show up in the home
stream and a notification means that
they're able to communicate really
directly with a lot of people I want to
change gears momentarily to talk about
2016 for Google+ because we had a really
exciting year last year among a number
of enhancements
and we launched give me major things and
I'm missing something on your heart
great most important one was missing big
milestone for us we launched Google+ as
a G suite core service last August and
we were privileged and excited to join
the ranks of products like calendar and
Gmail that are well used and loved by
our enterprises very exciting for us we
also rolled out the new Google+ web UI
to all of our users including enterprise
customers as well as consumers this new
web UI moves really seamlessly from
desktop to mobile really great for
employees on the go it also puts
knowledge sharing specifically through
communities and through collections
front and center to help companies make
sure that the folks that need that need
to be in a no stay in the know finally
we made significant improvements to
community moderation so this is a set of
tools that enabled community moderators
to take the reins of content coming into
their communities so included things
like the ability to approve every post
that comes into your community before it
shows up really good for communities
where you want to lock down the message
or to individually write whitelist users
you may have a set of users who you know
are great and should be posting into the
community and another set who you know
you want to review them a little more
we're excited to have this enhanced
suite of community moderation tool all
that said we firmly believe that this is
just the beginning for Google+ you guys
have all given us lots of feedback and
we've used that feedback to develop a
roadmap for the next year that focuses
on the needs of enterprises like yours
so for the first time ever I'm really
excited to today be able to talk about
the upcoming roadmap for 2017 what we're
going to be launching specifically for
enterprises using Google+
and and then at this point our lawyers
asked me to remind you that while we
strive to meet the timelines that I'm
going to talk about and to launch all
these features all this is subject to
change without notice fine print really
the lawyer line gets a laugh just when
you know you need better jokes so first
I want to talk about enhancements to
knowledge sharing the groove applies
today already provides the ability for
your employees to tap into knowledge and
expertise from across your organization
that they wouldn't otherwise have
accessed you over the next year we'll
continue to use Google smarts to enhance
our ability to deliver world-class
connectedness and knowledge sharing
across your enterprise for example by
tailoring recommended collections and
communities to the things that are most
important in your company this
investment in implying Google smarts to
your organization will make it even
easier for employees anywhere in your
company to find the content communities
and people that they should be in touch
with to be at their most innovative now
let's talk about employee engagement
this can mean for the Vanna beulah
subject you will want employee
engagement but how do you actually know
if your employees are engaged or if
they're engaged on Google+ can become so
we're excited to announce that we're
going to be introducing in the admin
console tools that directly allow you to
measure the engagement of your employees
on Google+ these metrics will allow
admins to dig into overall at overall
activity in your domain for example how
many posts are there how many comments
are there how many Plus Ones how many
folks are active on G+ on any given day
which communities have the most members
we're also going to give you access to
user level statistics so who in my
company is really active here who are
the drivers who are the opinion leaders
and finally down the road we'll also
introduce community level metrics so you
can see engagement in particular
communities finally let's talk a bit
about secure communications one thing
we've heard from many of you and
especially those in highly regulated
industries is the importance of being
able to track user activity at a
transaction level a really detailed
stuff right this year we'll introduce an
enterprise log API that will allow your
company or an authorized partner to
track the Google+ activity of specified
users in your domain for example you'll
be able to track in detail which posts
it a user make when did they edit them
which comments do they make when did
they remove or delete those giving you a
full trail of their activity this one
I'm really excited about in addition to
being able to track employee activity we
know many of you would like to have
further control over the extent to which
your employees are able to interact with
the outside world on Google+ we're
excited to announce that we're in the
process of developing new admin settings
that will allow you to select the level
of openness that's right for your
company so for this they're going to be
three levels of options the first level
and this is the current settings for all
domains using Google Plus is what we
call public public means that all of
your users are able to freely interact
within your domain as well as outside of
your domain this course still have the
ability to control who they share with
such that only people within the domain
can see it they can still lockdown
communities to within just your domain
but in addition they have the ability to
explore content shared outside of their
domain as well as to talk to customers
who may be in the outside world
to post on topics in which their thought
leaders the second option and this is
where we get into what's new is a
discovery mode so in this mode users can
still see content that's being posted
externally so they're able to see how
people are talking about your company
they're able to see what people are
posting in your industry but they're
restricted from sharing or commenting
externally this option is potentially
useful for folks who maybe shouldn't
have a public presence but still want to
be able to stay on top of what's
happening outside of your organization
the final option is what we call walled
garden this is the most locked down of
the options and in this mode users
aren't able to see external content in
recommendations and suggestions in
Google+ search and the escorts aren't
able to post or comment or +1 externally
either each of these options can be
customizable at a no u level so if you
wanted your marketing department to be
able to post externally but thought that
rng would be better served by a
discovery mode setting that's going to
be an option that's available to finally
we've heard lots of input from those of
you would like the ability to tighten
down security and be sure who's involved
in the conversation but who still wants
to be able to collaborate with people
outside of your domain for example you
may want to bring some potential ideas
with clients you may want to work with
partner teams you may want to talk to
employees and a sister company to allow
you to do that safely and securely we're
introducing multi domain communities so
these are communities that are domain
restricted but they're restricted to
multiple domains
right so you can have that secure
conversation be sure that things aren't
being leaked that people outside of the
domain aren't being invited but you're
able to do that with the companies that
we know you work with in your day to day
jobs it's securely restricted but now
collaborative - all right I know what
you've been waiting for I said we're
going to tell you when we were shipping
this thing so I guess I should actually
do that so we'll start by introducing
domain level user metrics in q2 into
three things start to really get real so
you'll see multi domain communities user
level usage metrics and the Google+
enterprise log API and then in q4 wells
garden which gives you three settings on
domain openness it's going to launch so
it's an exciting year for us and we hope
an exciting year for you as well by
helping you break down barriers and
share knowledge across your company
engage all your employees no matter
their level or location and providing
secure communications needed to discuss
new ideas we believe Google Plus can
help your company come together and do
more innovative work and while I'm
incredibly excited about all we've been
able to accomplish together
already I'm even more excited about
what's to come your partnership through
your trial your feedback your drive to
push to get even better is helping us
improve Google Plus and make it even
better serve your enterprises so thank
you for that looking forward to
unlocking even more innovation in your
enterprises together and thanks
everybody for taking the time and she's
going to come here about Google+
[Applause]